تحميل
وكان على مقروبه من الموت
ضابط ايقاع خط الوسط واحد ابرز نجوم
المنتخب الدنماركي
[موسيقى]
كريستيانو
متوسطه الحال وكان وحيد والديه حينها كان
في صغره هادئا خجولا انطوائيا يعشق كره
القدم بدا لاعبا لنادي البلده وتلقى عروضا
من عده فرق في عام 2008 انضم الى اكاديميه
اياكس امستردام الهولندي
الانجليزيه عام 2013 من بوابه النادي
اللندني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اما ركلاته الثابته فكانت مصيبه وخطيره
ومرعبه للحراس
[تصفيق]
بطوله يورو 2020 كانت نقطه فاصله في حياه
اريكسون وكادت تقضي على مسيرته المهنيه
نهائيا بل هو حياته ايضا
[موسيقى]
عليه فجاه خلال احدى المباريات بعد توقف
نبضات قلبه وسط ذهول الجماهير واللاعبين
الذين وقفوا مصدومين من هول المشهد هرع
اليه الطبيب وقدم له الانعاش القلبي
الرئوي ثم نقل الى المشفى حيث اجريت له
جراحه الناجحه وغادره بعد ايام
الزمه الاطباء بزرع جهاز تنظيم ضربات
القلب للعوده الى الملاعب ما دفع نادي
انتر ميلان الذي انتقل اليه قبل موسم وحقق
معه اللقب لسكودوتو الي فسخ عقده بالتراضي
بسبب مخالفه ذلك لوائح الدوري الايطالي
عاد الى كره القدم بعد ان ظن الجميع ان
مسيرته الكرويه قد انتهت من بوابه
الانجليزيه وسط تصفيق الجماهير التي
احتفلت بعودته الى المستطيل الاخضر
[تصفيق]
انتبه نادي مانشستر يونايتد منذ بدايه
الموسم بعقد لثلاث سنوات وحجز لنفسه مكانا
اساسيا في كتيبه الهولندي تين هاد
[تصفيق]
حكايه طفل عاشق كره القدم منذ طفولته وخرج
من بلدته الهادئه الصغيره ليظهر موهبته
للعالم كان قريبا من الموت في المستطيل
الذي امضى حياته فيه واستيقظ مره اخرى
لمواصله حلمه
[تصفيق]